so like what do you guys do when those
are funny responses so what do you guys
do when women come at you with um stuff
like um follow my instagram like sign up
for my only fans i'm looking for a sugar
daddy like what do you mean yeah
yeah
just laugh laughing
here's how i've had it happen to me
whether i'm like hey look
because they can tell usually
here's another thing i didn't know until
i was starting to chat with a lot of
these gals um your name comes up i have
my first and last name on there so as
soon as they match they can actually see
both right and so
i'm a pretty easy google search
so
i don't get a lot of that stuff what i
do get is
i'll say hey look i'm pretty busy guy
like let's meet for a drink or two
if it works out we'll plant something
else in the future but i don't want to
waste a lot of our time and i'll get the
girls that say like well you know i want
to go on a proper date and i want to be
taken out to dinner i'm like okay then
you probably need to go see somebody
else because i i've got way too much
stuff going on and you literally run you
guys know how it is you like run through
these chicks like this one's crazy this
one's got this one like you could tell
within a couple of drinks it's like all
right this is you know i gotta move on
here the girls that do that kind of
stuff are losing on their side of the
game so if you look at it it's all just
a game and if you approach it just like
having fun and the more people that play
the game the more the the cheaper you're
gonna sell yourself because the market's
saturated so these girls that are like
oh i want a proper date
okay you're sorry you're 29 looks are
fading maybe you didn't take care of
yourself your skin's starting to age
i've got a 20 year old who's game to do
anything i want
and she's on the way over now if i want
her to so who are you competing that a
lot of girls don't realize that they're
competing in a sexual marketplace too so
for me those kind of ones i'm like
i'm nice i'm cordial but i you you learn
to play the game like a girl does
essentially guys you learn to dismiss
them just real let them down real soft
real easy
you don't want to score because then
they'll follow you on social media and
stalk you and bottom line is it's not
genuine desire because because she's
trying to
negotiate something
like follow me for you know become one
of my beta orbiters or give me money or
give me money over here so you look at
pictures of my butthole or whatever and
you i think it's important to double
down on wingman's point though as far as
leading i think it's funny because i
think a lot of guys gravitate to bumble
because most dudes are so ner what
what's the one the the biggest question
that guys and pick up or talking chicks
get asked how do you open a girl what do
i say to her what's what do i say my
name is right but i'm saying like go so
guys go to bumble and that's a really
interesting one because it's a coke it's
like oh cool like now the work is done
for me
and they don't understand that
99.99 of girls don't have game and they
open with the same boring bs that a guy
was like hey how's it going hey how was
your weekend or some like
pancakes or waffles yeah and guys are
pissed and they're like what
what do you what the hell is this
they're low-tier women on those apps
when girls would do that with me i don't
even address it i just go in and i start
the conversation on something completely
different i don't even answer the
question i don't answer how my weekend
was i don't i just say i'm now in
control of this conversation i'm leading
it where i want to go and 99 of the time
they don't care because they just want
the burden off of them of having to make
the small talk in the bs i just think
it's a completely different on a
completely different tangent would you
get incredibly frustrated with
the amount of work that they put into
dating with the returns that they get
trust me like there's not a lot of guys
that have game like what like the stuff
that we're talking about here
is
level 10 like pay attention tonight
guys what's up paul
what's up man
how do i sound i don't know yeah you
sound like you sound good it's just a
little muffled but we can hear you you
know one of the things i found is i
absolutely love
there you go i absolutely love uh
going out and picking up like
here's here's what i found it's like it
doesn't matter what you say
like none of that matters like oh
this is the opener i got just say it
with a little bit of confidence so
there's a couple of guys i'll go out
with and we've got some rules so let's
say there's a table of girls four or
five girls
you really want that 50 ratio you don't
want like all these dudes you know kind
of like hunting these handful of chicks
right and so the the deal i got with
some buddies of mine i said look
if you think she's cute you can go over
there
introduce yourself or whatever you think
game is you go do that
so they get about 30 seconds and i tried
this to be honest we were at a happy
hour and i was a couple a couple of
drinks in i'm like you know i'm gonna
let this one rip so i lean over to this
table of girls and i said hey my gay
boyfriend thinks you're cute
they all start live obviously we're not
gay right i mean you can tell in two
seconds
but what was fun is the one guy gets up
and goes don't read the comments
afterward jason so oh yeah
fair warning
yeah because they were going to say
that's self-deprecating bro you
shouldn't do that it's low va whatever
but we hope we had a great time and i i
think with a lot of this dating app and
a lot of this stuff like you had said
earlier rich like these guys spurred out
in this stuff and it's like it's not
that hard dude just be confident and
just say look this is how i do it we
start matching the chat for a couple
minutes okay great look i'm not on these
apps all the time
so here's my number send me a text
or you give me your number and i'll text
you i don't care here's my number we'll
text back and forth right and then
you're immediately like now you're going
back and forth okay cool i'm gonna meet
you tuesday uh well i can do thursday
sorry i can't see you till next week the
guys are making this way harder than it
needs to be like i i kind of look at it
as sales it's like all i'm trying to do
is get in front of the
opportunity here and maybe it's an
opportunity maybe it's just a prospect
and not an opportunity but let's get in
front let's see what's let's see what's
going on here yeah but jb let's talk
about that real quick right this is
something that like
this be confident
thing right i mean confidence comes from
competence so i mean
it's one of those like where does that
come from right i mean you have a high
degree of success you have you know
experience now you've got wins that
you've stacked you know if we're if
we're talking to the everyman here i
mean i equate be confident almost or if
on the same plane as just be yourself
because it's like where where does that
like how do i build off of that where
does conference go from right how do i
get there so
because i think do you make it is i
don't i don't buy it because i think if
we if we know anything about women and
how good they are picking up on covert
communication and bs they're better
picking up than we are as guys so they
can spell that
both both moff and bible mean the same
thing it's just bible's definition of
confidence you know can be expanded on
different ways right i mean you could
literally message a check
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious
and if you look like the hot dude from
the phone cannon party and you got your
together and you have a wonderful
life that she looks like she might want
to be invited into to hang out with
she'll be like hey what's up
yeah what i would say
she'll look at your instagram and be
like oh you're hot like are you in town
what are you what are you doing what
plans this weekend they'll come to you
if you present them a good enough
opportunity or or representation of
what your lifestyle is like but another
thing is you actually have to live that
lifestyle so
there's still a gap between reality and
what i call the analog world in the
digital world
if you can bridge that gap in your life
online it reflects your life in real
life in the analog world then
it's a lot easier because then then
essentially i just invite girls to join
my day uh my day's already interesting
so it's just if you show up great if not
my day's still gonna be great so i mean
to mop's point i think to address this
question what i would say is that you
know i would translate be confident and
be yourself right as to go out there and
try right because all right again
talking to the guy that's hey
i'm i just turned 23 i you know have
absolutely i'm starting from ground zero
some scratch right the idea and thought
of like oh i'm gonna go out and like
have this confidence and swag right it's
it's probably gonna be seem like you
know you're talking about hey let's get
from here to mars so i would say like
you know what um the core message is hey
go out and try right you have to go out
and try different things you have to go
out and you have to make those
approaches whether they're virtual
approaches where you're talking to
people online and trying to get matches
or their in-person approaches you have
to go out and you have to try it's a
continuous learning process and from
that you start to build and piece
together elements that you can then
incorporate into an overall formula that
really works for yourself and you can
kind of discover your own sort of
personal science that really enables you
to maximize the connections that you're
having and the direction you want to
take them so that would be the advice
like that breakdown i think that's
important to differentiate i think that
we need to take it that step further and
granulate it a little bit
you